Hello everyone and uh welcome to lecture
8 of CME295.
So today's topic will be LLM evaluation
and I think this class is probably one
of the most important classes of this uh
quarter because the idea is if we don't
know how to measure the performance of
our LLM, we don't really know what to
improve and so this class will focus on
how we can quantify how the LLM performs
in a bunch of different cases.
So with that said, we are going to start
the class as usual by recapping what we
saw last week. So if you remember last
week, we saw how our LLM could interact
with systems that are outside of the LM
itself. So we saw one core technique
that is called rag that allows our LLM
to fetch information from external
knowledge bases. And so here rag stands
for retrieval augmented generation
and we saw how we could uh improve the
retrieval system. So we saw uh that it
was composed of two main steps. So one
was candidate retrieval which is
typically something that is done with uh
a c by encoder kind of setup. So
sentence spurt was uh like a good
example of how people would design such
a model. Um and so this first step is
typically there to filter down the
potential relevant candidates for a
given incoming query.
And then we saw that there was a second
step which was um reranking and that one
was a bit more involved and involved
cross encoders which were most
sophisticated.
And we also saw some ways to quantify
how well our retrieval system performed.
And then we also saw something that was
called tool calling which is the ability
for our model to know which tool to call
with which argument.
So if you remember, if we give our LLM
the knowledge of the tools that are
available to to it, it can figure out
which arguments it needs to input to the
function as a function of the input
query and then run that function and
then output the result in natural
language to the user.
And then we also saw how agentic
workflows were composed of. So uh
spoiler alert is something that is a
combination of the two [snorts] previous
methods. So rag and tool calling and in
particular
given an input we're allowing our model
to make multiple calls
to call different tools to fetch
relevant data from uh other uh knowledge
bases and uh we saw one example that was
kind of successful uh from the current
applications which was AI assisted
coding which relies on this principle
And react is typically the framework
that people would use. So reason plus
act which is decomposing this into
observe, plan and act steps.
Cool. So this is what we saw last time
and we also started from this slide last
time. We, you know, if you remember, our
LLM has strength but also weaknesses
that we're trying to mitigate. So, in
particular, the focus of lectures six
and seven were on methods to improve
reasoning of the model and ways to for
the model to fetch knowledge from other
systems as well as performing actions.
And today we're going to focus on the
evaluation part. In particular, given a
response that the model is giving, how
can we quantify how well the LLM is
giving its response?
Cool. So first of all, I would like to
define the term evaluation and the
meaning that we will use for this
lecture. So when we say I want to
evaluate my LLM, it can actually take a
lot of different meanings.
So when you say let's evaluate the LLM,
it can mean let's evaluate the
performance, the output, let's evaluate
this based on coherence, factuality.
Let's evaluate it based on latency. So
more system related metrics or pricing
or how often it is up and so on.
So just to make sure we're on the same
page, this lecture will mostly focus on
the output quality parts and in
particular we'll focus on quantifying
how good the actual response is.
And here you will note that this is a
challenging problem because um as we saw
previously our LLM is a texttoext
model that can output basically
anything.
So it can be natural language, it can be
code, it can be math reasoning and so on
and so forth. So it's very hard to come
up with universal metrics to evaluate
that. So we will see how people do this
in practice.
Cool. So given the fact that our LLM
generates free form output,
one could imagine that the ideal
scenario for us to evaluate the LLM
output would be to every time ask a
human to rate the response.
So here the ideal scenario would be okay
I give a prompt to my LLM. It gives a
response. I ask a human to rate it and I
start again and again
and uh what I do is at the end of the
day I just collect all these human
responses and I try to quantify the
overall performance of my model. Well,
as you can imagine, the main problem is
that such a system would be very cost
intensive.
But let's look at this into more detail.
So
if you remember
the LLM outputs are really free form and
there may be cases that even human
judgment may be something that is fuzzy
because maybe the rating task in itself
is subjective.
So let's take the following example.
Let's suppose I ask my LLM what birthday
gift should I get? And let's suppose the
LLM responds with a teddy bear is almost
always a sweet gift. Just pick one that
feels right for you. So let's suppose I
want to evaluate this response with
respect to the usefulness dimension.
I may have one human raider that says,
"Yeah, it's pretty useful because you
know like teddy bear is pretty
indicative of um I guess the what the
user should get as a gift." But then
another raider may say, "No, actually
it's not useful because maybe the
response didn't specify exactly which
teddy bear. Should I have a bear? Should
I have an elephant, a giraffe? Like
which stuffed animal should I get?"
And so there is this um notion of
interrator agreements
where we're bas basically
um concerned with making sure that
everyone is aligned on how to rate those
responses
because sometimes like in this
illustrative example
it may be a little bit subjective.
So responses may vary. So what people
want to do is to make sure that the
guidelines are clear enough for everyone
to rate these responses in a consistent
manner.
So people come up with um agreement
types of metrics.
So a very natural metric that you may
think of is the quote unquote agreement
rates.
So for instance you have this uh two
raiders. So what you do is you just um
measure the proportion of the time that
the two raiders give the same response.
And let's suppose the response here is
binary. So let's say yes good or not
good.
Well do you see a problem with such a
metric?
like is this a good metric?
I guess another way to ask this question
is if I give you a given number of
agreement rates, can you tell me if it's
a good number or if it's a bad number?
Well, let's take the example of let's
say two raiders.
um let's say Alice
and let's say Bob
and let's suppose we have two different
types of ratings that these raiders can
give. So either let's say uh yes it's
good so one the output is good or the
output is not good.
So if we assume that the first raider
gives let's say random responses
with some probability P of A for being
good and one minus P of A for being not
good and then let's say Bob who should
have eyes and a smile
has uh P of B for being good and one
minus P of B for being not
Then
let's compute the agreement rate for
this case. So the agreement rate
is basically the probability
that
raider A and raider B
agree.
And so here A and B agree.
if A and B both vote one
or way when A and B both vote zero,
right?
But if they give the their response in
an independent and random way,
well, if you use like these probability
concepts that you know, then we will
have
probability of A and B responding to
one, which is probability of A
responding to one time probability of B
responding to one and same for zero. So
we will have something like this.
So P of A P of B
plus 1 - P of A
1 - P of B.
So this one is A and B
say 1
and here A and B
say zero.
So,
so let's see what the agreement rate
would be in that case.
So if we assume that
suppose that let's suppose uh P of A is
equal to P of B which is equal to let's
say.5
then the agreement rate would be so
agreement rate
would be so I'm just replacing the
numbers here so.5
squared +.5^
squar. So it's 0.25 + 25 which is equal
to.5. So what that means is
if we're just letting our raers
rate these things in a random way with
some probability, you know, P of A, P of
B, we would already have an agreement
rate of 50%. Just by pure random chance.
And so
one thing that I want to say is that
this agreement rate by pure chance
is a function of the probability that
each of these raiders give these
ratings.
And so if
this probability is actually higher the
agreement rate by pure chance is also
higher.
So what that means? So what do I want to
say?
I want to say that if we just take the
agreement rates then it's very hard to
put it into context in terms of what you
would have gotten if things would have
happened just by pure chance.
So for this reason,
people have come up with a series of
metrics that try to make it more
relative to this baseline, which is what
would happen if our raiders would choose
things kind of randomly.
And so you have these metrics like for
instance this one is the coins scapa
metric which
computes a quantity that is a function
of this agreement rate by chance
and take the observed one
such that if our observed agreement rate
is greater than the by chance agreement
rates
then our coefficient is positive. So
when it's positive you know at least you
know it's going in the right direction.
So here if the observed agreement rate
is equal to one
then alpha is so kappa is equal to one.
But if our observed agreement rate is
below the you know by pure random chance
erment rate that we saw on the
blackboard then our coefficient would be
negative.
So long story short, there is a bunch of
metrics that try to quantify interrator
agreement rates using these kinds of
formulas to be able to make these
quantities relative to what would happen
if things were done in a random way.
And so that's why you may see a bunch of
metrics out there. So here it's cohen
scappa that people use for cases where
there are tool raiders but then you have
extensions such as fly scapa and
crypendors alpha that you may see out
there. So they all rely on this idea
that we should have some baseline
which is
you know our raiders just randomly
picking answers and try to see how much
better our actual agreement is compared
to this.
So does that make sense?
Yeah. So I guess what I want to say is
that the first limitation of asking
humans
to rate our LM outputs which was
sometimes the task being subjective
can be something that we can quantify
with this interrator agreement metrics.
So what people typically do is they keep
track of how good that agreement is. And
if let's say we have a quantity that's
not satisfactory,
people would just hold some quote
unquote agreement sessions between the
raiders to just align on how they should
rate the answers.
So that it can be seen as just a health
metric to track how consistent your
rating are and this is typically
something that people use in practice.
So
up until now we've seen one limitation
of human ratings.
Well second limitation I think I also
said this previously. So it's really
slow. You know, if you ask someone to
rate a thousand LM outputs, well, it
will take them a while and it's of
course expensive.
So, all of that to say that our ideal
scenario of asking a human to rate every
LLM output is not something that is
practical.
But we can leverage human
ratings in some way because we've seen
that even if the task is subjective, we
can have a way to align our raiders.
So now let's move on to another way to
go about doing this, which is by using
some rule-based metrics.
So here I'm just going to revise the
setting that I mentioned before
and instead of asking our humans to
write every LLM output,
this time I'm just going to ask them to
write
the references or the ideal outputs for
a given set of prompts. just fix that
for good
and then use some kind of metric that
would compare the LLM outputs
with those references.
So here the main difference is let's
suppose I have a given set of prompts
fixed.
Well, I can make iterations in my model
and always compare the output of my LLM
with this fixed reference instead of
always asking humans to rate that again
and again. So, it's already an
improvement
and we will see a little bit what are
the kinds of rulebased metrics that you
will see out there.
So ideally these metrics should reflect
the performance of the LM output in a in
an optimal way. And what I mean by an
optimal way, it is to make it be a
little bit flexible given the fact that
natural language is not always something
that you can say in one given way.
So for instance when I provide a
response to a given prompt there can be
very well a case where I can formulate
the response slightly differently but it
will still be just as good.
So the idea behind this metrics is to
make this comparison
a little bit flexible.
So let's start with one common one that
people use in the translation case. So
this metric is called meteor and it
stands for metric for evaluation of
translation with explicit ordering.
So the idea here is to compare
reference and predicted and we'll see
how it's being done and also
penalize cases when words are not in the
same order which is explaining why the
metric is called with explicit ordering.
So the formula is as follows. So it is
some fcore times 1 minus some penalty.
So the fcore here is so you may be
familiar with f1 score. So it's like the
harmonic mean with equal weights. So
this one is with the variable weights.
So it is a function of precision and
recall
where precision is the proportion of the
unigs that are in your predicted
sequence
that are matching with the reference and
the recall is the proportion of the
unigs in the reference
that are matching with what is in the
predicted. So it's basically matching
the
usual precision recall metrics that you
know and then we have another quantity
here which is the penalty and I
mentioned the penalty here tries to
incentivize
goods ordering. So if it's ordered the
same in the reference and in the
prediction then it's good otherwise it's
bad.
And so here there's a bunch of
quantities. So gamma and beta are
hyperparameters that people arbitrarily
choose.
And it's a function of C,
the number of contiguous chunks that are
matched
over the matched unigs. The number of
matched unigs.
So ideally you would want
C that would be as low as possible
because if you have a low number of
contiguous matches
it means that your contiguous sequences
are are long
which means that the ordering is the
same.
So you want C to be low
and then matched unigs to be high.
So you want that penalty term to be low
for a good I guess for a prediction that
has the same ordering as the reference.
So I guess
higher meter score means better
translation AC according to this way of
doing things.
So I guess when you look at this formula
so first of all it seems it looks very
arbitrary
right I have uh alpha as a
hyperparameter gamma beta so it's kind
of a
a recipe I feel so that's one
and the second thing is that it does not
allow for stylistic variations because
here we're measuring the number of
matched unigs
Although the metric expands the like
range of what is called matched unigs by
taking into account things like words
that are synonyms of one another and
things that are of the same roots
but still it is not like extremely uh
satisfactory in that sense.
So mter is meteor is one such metric.
You have another one that's being used
or that has been used in translation
tasks which is called blur which you may
know. So, BL stands for bilingual
evaluation under study. And you can
think of this as kind of a precision
focused kind of metric
that uh looks at the number of matched
the matching engrams
over the engrams that are in the
prediction, which is why it's a
precision kind of metric.
And it also has uh a penalty term here.
It's called brevity penalty
because given that it's more of a
precision kind of metric. If you
translate something that's very short,
you may be able to gain the the metric.
So you want to penalize
the translation being too short.
So we'll not go into a lot of details,
but I just want to just show you the
kinds of metrics that are out there. So
meter is one, blue is another one and
rouge which you may have heard is also
another one typically used for
summarization tasks.
Again same idea and um it has a bunch of
varants that you may see out there
but long story short all these metrics
they all compare
the output with a reference.
So as we saw one key limitation is that
they do not allow stylistic variation.
So let's take an example. So let's
suppose I say a plush teddy bear can
comfort a child during bedtime. Well,
the exact same thing I can say it I can
say it in a really different way. So
soft, stuffed uh bears often help kids
feel safe as they fall asleep or many
youngsters rest more easily at night
when they cuddle a gentle toy companion.
So in all these cases, the metrics that
we saw would you would really perform
very poorly.
So that's one key limitation. So the
second key limitation is correlation is
not that great.
I mean, you can imagine that people have
come up with all these hyperparameters
to kind of make it be correlated to
human ratings, but they're not that
correlated.
And the bottom line is it still requires
human ratings
to just get started. And sometimes
you just can't afford to have human
ratings maybe in your project.
So I guess there are still some key
limitations
which is the reason why. So all of that
to say I want to motivate the key method
of this class or of this lecture which
is called LLM as a judge.
So, you know, we spent the first seven
lectures motivating these large language
models that are pre-trained on huge
amounts of data that are uh tuned in a
way to match human preference. So, they
do contain human knowledge. They do
contain some indication of what humans
may prefer.
So the idea here is to have our model
response
be actually an input of yet another LLM
and that LLM is something that people
typically call LLM as a judge.
So it was a term that was introduced in
a paper uh from two years ago.
So here the idea is to use an LLM for
rating purposes
and things that you would see as input
would be the prompt that was used to
produce the response,
the response
and the criteria along which you want to
grade your response.
And so here LLM as a judge would give
you the following outputs. So the first
thing is it would give you a score.
So here you can think of it as like a
binary scale kind of score. So pass or
fail
but and this is very new
also a rationale
because LLMs they understand text
so they can also explain you why they
graded something with a given score
and that part is
the key difference with previous
methods. we are able to explain why the
metric or the model is giving us a given
score. And this is quite quite good
because in the other let's say rulebased
worlds where you would have all these
like formulas and multiplication all
these things and sometimes you would
come up with a number that would not be
very self-explanatory
and this is luckily something that LM as
a judge addresses.
So to recap,
what we want is to use an LLM as a way
to grade the response.
So here you would have typically
the following kind of prompts. So you
would state okay I want to evaluate my
response with respect to a given
criteria
and then you give the prompt that you
used to generate that response along
with the model response
and then you would ask
the judge to return two things the
rationale and then the score.
So one little trick I want to point out
is people typically ask the model to
first output the rationale and then the
score
and the reason why we typically do that
is it's something that empirically
improves the quality of the results
but then given what we saw I think in
lecture six if you remember the
reasoning class we saw that these
reasoning models that are being trendy
especially in 2025
what they do is they first output a
chain of thought before giving the
answer.
So you can actually think of this trick
as being on the same kind of idea of
reasoning models as in it allows the
model to
externalize verbalize its quote unquote
thought process before giving the score.
So it gives it a chance to really figure
out what is good or what is wrong in the
model response.
So far so good.
Any questions on I guess the setup?
Yeah, all good. Okay. So now I have a
question for you.
If I give the following prompt to my LM
as a judge,
am I guaranteed to have a rational and a
score that I can parse?
Am I guaranteed?
No. Yeah, exactly. No. The answer is no.
You're not guaranteed to have um a
rational and a score that you can parse
because this model has some
probabilistic nature to it with the
sampling process and it's not something
that you can really control. So I guess
my follow-up question is do you know a
technique that would
I guess guarantee you to have um a
structured response. So hint is a it's a
technique that we seen that we saw like
towards the beginning of the class.
Okay, I'll give you a little hint. So if
you remember on slide 65 of lecture 3,
we saw a technique called constrained
guided decoding.
So if you remember the idea here is to
constrain the decoding part pro process
by allowing our model to only sample
from quote unquote valid tokens.
And we typically do that in cases where
we want our output to have a given
format. So let's suppose a JSON format
and we want absolutely that format.
So what people do is they use this
technique to guarantee the form of the
response.
And in case you're using these provider
like the providers that are you know out
there like for instance open AAI or
Gemini or anthropic
this technique is known under the name
structured output.
So in your project if you want to
constrain the decoding process
in order to output a response of a given
format. So let's suppose my format is a
response and I kind of represent it by a
class and there are like two attributes
so rational and score.
Well typically you can reference that
with the argument text format equal to
that representation.
So, this I believe is something that uh
OpenAI does, and I'm not exactly sure if
it's exactly the argument name that you
would see for the other providers, but
they're all I guess along the same
lines.
Does that sound good? So, the key word
here is structured output. Whenever you
want a response of a given format, you
would just go for that.
Okay, cool. So just to recap, our LLM as
a judge has two main benefits. So the
first one is that we do not need a
reference text. We do not need human
ratings to just get started because our
LLM already has a lot of I guess
knowledge that has acquired during
pre-training and human preferences and
so on. So you do not need that.
And then the second thing is you can
interpret the score with the rationale
that is being output
and that is also quite remarkable.
So just as an example so here you would
say okay evaluate the quality of like
this this response. So you would have
some rational that would explain what
this response has or doesn't have that
makes it good or bad
along with the score.
Okay, cool. And I believe uh Okay, so
now we're going to see the kinds of LM
messages that you can see out there. So
of course there are many variations but
there are generally two types of L me
that you will see.
So the first one is you have a single
output a single response that you want
to evaluate
and here you would ask LS judge to say
okay is it good or is it not good
and the second big kind of LS judge that
you will see out there is pairwise kind
of setup. So you have two responses and
you say is response A better or is
response B better
and here you would obtain a response
either okay that one or this one.
So if you remember we've seen uh in
previous lectures that there are a lot
of situations where we would want to
have preference data. So for instance in
the preference tuning class that we had
I believe it was lecture five.
So this kind of method can also be a
good way to synthetically generate
preference ratings
where you have two responses
and then you ask your LLM to say okay I
prefer that one and you can use that one
as a as the label to train your rework
model.
Does it sound good?
Any questions on the setup or
everything that we've talked about so
far?
Okay, cool. Everyone is uh on the same
page. So now let's see what can go wrong
with our LMS as a judge. So uh let's
think of the possible kinds of failures
that we can encounter.
So the first one is called position bias
and as the name suggests it has to do
with the ordering at which we present
the responses to our model.
So let's say if we ask our model is
response A better or response B.
Well, there is a chance that the model
responds with response A just because it
it was the first one to be mentioned.
So that kind of bias is called position
bias. So it's where the position at
which you place the response matters in
the
judgment of the LMS as a judge model.
And I guess as a way to remedy that,
people have different techniques. But
one typical technique would be to ask
the model is A or B better and then ask
the model is B or A better and then take
the majority voting. So if both of them
lead to the same response, then it's
good. But if the response changes,
then it may not be good. So you may want
to do something else.
Um there are a bunch of other
techniques. So I know there's a bunch of
papers that try to tweak the position
embeddings but those ones are a bit more
advanced. So it's not typically the
thing that you would do just out of the
box. So taking the average or like you
know taking the majority voting of this
you know position swapping is CPT what
you would do.
Okay, cool. So this was the first kind
of bias. The second bias is called
verbosity bias.
So let's suppose you have two responses
and the first response is short and
concise.
The second response is something that
goes much more into details is typically
something that is more verbose.
Well, there are cases where the model
will tend to um
to I guess prefer responses that are
just more verbose just because they're
more verbose, not necessarily because
they're more correct.
And for that, it's maybe a little bit
trickier. So
people typically try to explicit
this dimension in the guidelines
when they input I guess the this this
question to the LMS as a judge they say
uh well make sure to not pay too much
attention to the length of these
responses to not I guess prefer
something just because it's more
verbose.
So that's one kind of meth method that
you will see out there.
Uh the second one is to just um also add
some examples in context learning
examples
uh to the model to just um I guess tell
it to
um I guess show by example that
verbosity is not something you should uh
prefer. And then uh the last one is to
have some kind of penalty
on the output length.
So you can ask your model in a pointwise
way is one how how good is one how good
is two and then try to penalize that
with the length. So that's something
that also people may use.
Okay. So we've seen position bias, we've
seen verbosity bias, now we will see the
third kind of bias that you may see out
there which is called selfenhancement
bias.
And so that one has to do with the fact
that if you ask a model to judge an
output
that was produced by itself,
well, the model will tend to prefer
responses that are generated by itself
regardless of whether or not the other
one was more
uh aligned with what we wanted.
And I guess here the intuition is that
if our model
generated such an answer then it's maybe
the case that
uh our model thought that from a
probabilistic standpoint this was a
sequence that was very much likely to
appear. So it may be I guess one way to
think about it which is if it has
generated such a sequence then it means
that it it is something that
it thinks I mean think uh quote unquote
that it's a good answer.
So the general guideline here is to
typically not use the same model that
you use for generation and for
judges.
But um I guess nowadays it's kind of
hard to have that strict
uh constraints um I guess
uh respected because I guess all models
they are trained on basically the same
data sets.
So you can argue they're all being
subject to the same I guess training
mixes and so on. But still I guess
people what what people do is they tend
to use another model just to have
such a risk be minimized. So long story
short try to not use the exact same
model that you use for generation
and for evaluation.
So this is self- enhancement bias.
Okay. So before we go to the next uh
subp part I guess what do you think of
these three biases? Do they make sense?
Any questions so far?
Yep.
So, can you elaborate a bit more?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, the question is,
can you have a model that just maybe
isn't aligned with uh I guess the ground
truth and maybe prioritizes maybe one
label over another. So, yeah, this can
definitely be another kind of bias. Uh
so this bias being that our LLM is not
exactly aligned with what humans would
prefer. So these three biases are by no
means exhaustive. So this can very well
be another bias that you can list as
well. Um so yeah, this is definitely
another kind of bias.
Yep.
So the question is, is it possible that
our judge still prefers an LM response
even if it's a different one? Well, it
depends how good your judge is. But
typically the best practice is to have a
judge that has a much bigger capacity
that may capture these kind of
differences and not be fooled by a
response that just sounds like something
it may generate but something that is
maybe more aligned with human
preferences. So I guess the short answer
is yes, you can still have such a
situation. But in order to mitigate that
risk, you would typically take a model
that is not the same but also typically
much bigger.
So uh you have a bunch of uh such models
out there and uh you know with all the I
guess um improvements that have been
made with like reasoning models. This is
also something that people try.
Yeah, question is should the judge be
bigger? Um, it's not a hard constraint,
but it's typically something that people
would take like a bigger model that
would have strong reasoning capabilities
that could really tease out what's good
and what's not good. Yeah.
Okay, cool. So, with that, I'm going to
just go over the best practices that
we've seen. So we saw that um in order
for our LMS as a judge to output a
score, we need to give the criteria that
we want this to be evaluated against.
But sometimes this criteria may be a
little bit subjective. So one thing that
really works very well is to have crisp
guidelines. So really explicit what we
want, what we don't want.
The other point is you may see different
kinds of scaling out there. So sometimes
people having uh a scale that is maybe
more granular and maybe other cases
where we're just operating on a binary
scale. So typically what people would
tend to prefer is actually the binary
one because it makes the job of the LM
as a judge easier. So it's just either
good or bad.
And also when it comes to aligning the
judge with human ratings, humans, they
typically also find it easier to just
judge out of two options as opposed to
several. So it just removes the noise of
having several uh possible choices. And
it's not necessarily an extra signal
that may be really useful. So here the
tip is to use a binary scale like a pass
or fail kind of score as opposed to like
a gradual one.
The third tip is to make sure to output
the rational before outputting the
score.
And we've seen this is along the same
ideas of outputting a chain of thought
before providing the response which is
something that is done by our reasoning
models. So it's typically something that
will improve uh the judge performance.
Uh so we've talked about the different
kinds of biases. So position, verbosity,
self-enhancement, but it's not the only
ones of course and uh I guess people
typically also look at how to mitigate
those with the remedies that we
mentioned.
So, so far we've stated that we do not
need human ratings to get started,
but a good practice is to still look at
how the LLM ratings compare with the
human ratings.
So here one tip is to just calibrate the
responses that the judge is giving with
respect to the human ratings because at
the end of the day it is the quantity
that we want to approximate
and so here I guess if there is the
budget and it's something that is
possible for the project one good uh
practice is to collect the human ratings
output the LM as a judge scores and then
run some correlation analysis. this to
see if there is something that can be uh
improved in terms of the prompt mainly
the prompt
and then the last thing is the
temperature.
So if you remember the temperature
um is a parameter that you can tweak to
make your generation more deterministic
as opposed to more creative. And so you
will see that for evaluation tasks,
people use a low temperature because
they want to make their evaluation
experiments reproducible.
Like let's imagine you do one evaluation
and then you do another one let's say uh
two days later. You don't want the
scores to be super different. So you
will see a temperature value of
something [snorts] like 0.1 or 0 2.
These are like very uh common values
that people take.
And so long story short, if we were to
recap, we went from the ideal scenario
being that
each LM output is rated by humans
to actually having some kind of
approximation with these LM as a judge
models that can do this evaluation I
guess um without any constraints or
without any need for human judge. ments.
But as we mentioned in the best
practices,
making sure that the LMS adjust scores
and the human ratings do not diverge is
something that we should keep in mind as
we improve our model
because it may be that we're improving
on our model
so that our LMS score is very high but
the LMS score is itself an approximation
of human ratings. So I guess you don't
want to overoptimize against the I guess
a proxy. And so that's why you want to
have that proxy be as aligned as
possible with your ground truth labels
which are human ratings.
Okay, cool. Um so uh we have a few
minutes left before giving it to
Shervin. So I'm going to quickly go over
the kinds of dimensions that people uh
measure uh LM output against. So we have
broadly so there are many dimensions but
just to simplify things there are two
main dimensions that we can look at
here. So one is how well your task is uh
being done. So task performance with
things like was the response useful, was
the response factual, was the response
relevant among other things. And also
how aligned
was the response format in terms of tone
is in terms of whether the style was
something that is aligned what we want
in terms of whether there was any unsafe
elements of response that was given to
the user.
And I just want us to spend maybe five
minutes on the facility dimension
which is actually something that
requires a little bit more work
and I'll give you just a setting.
So let's suppose we have some text
output
and our goal is to quantify how factual
that output is. So I'm going to read the
text out loud. So teddy bears first
created in the 1920s were named after
President Theodore Roosevelt after he
proudly wanted to shoot a captured bear
on a hunting trip. So what we want is
quantify how factual that piece of text
is.
So I told you pre previously that um we
typically prefer binary scales when it
comes to rating
uh something with respect to a
dimension.
But the thing with factuality is that
there's a lot of nuance.
Some text may be very wrong. Some text
may be a little bit wrong. Some text may
be not wrong at all. So we want to
capture how wrong the text is. given the
the fact that the text can contain a lot
of sentences and if there's like one
small issue, we don't want to just say
the whole thing was not correct.
So, I'm not sure if you saw in this
text, but there are actually two errors.
So, it's not 1920s, but 1900s that the
teddy bears were first created. And uh
the president didn't want to proudly
shoot. He actually I think refused. So
if we are in such a case the question
that we want to tackle here is how do we
want to quantify
this nuance.
So this is an open question that people
have been writing papers on. So what I'm
going to tell you now
is something that people typically use
nowadays based on re research that has
been done.
So we typically operate in a few steps.
So the first step is for us to go from
the original text output
to a list of facts
because when you look at a text, it
actually contains a lot of facts that
need to be checked. And so the idea here
is to aggregate
the factuality of this text along the
dimension of the facts that are present
in this text.
So in this example, we would have one
LLM call that transforms our original
multi-sentence multiaragraph potentially
text
into a list of list of facts. So here in
this example we would have four facts.
So that's the first step. The second
step is we would go over each of these
facts
and check whether it is correct or not.
And so here we would typically proceed
in a binary fashion
because when if you think about it a
fact is either correct or not. I mean
you may have some in between but we
don't want to over complicate the ta the
task
and so here the factchecking process
would typically involve the other
technique we've seen last lecture like
rag for instance given a piece of text
we want to I guess query a knowledge
base with the actual fact and then check
whether the fact that is here is
actually correct
So this facteing process is typically
something that involves things like rag
web search is also something else
and so on.
So you can think of this facteing step
as also involving
LLM calls.
And so you can also think of some facts
being more important than others.
So as an example, maybe the fact that
the president proudly wanted to shoot
the the bear is not as important as
let's say the name of the person after
which the teddy bears were named. So you
can think of also having weights that
quantifies
the importance of each fact.
So people would use something
like this formula which is an
aggregation over all the facts with some
weight that quantifies the importance of
each fact.
So these weights alpha I can be all
equal to one another if you want to make
it simpler. It's not something that is
necessarily
uh the case everywhere that these must
be different but it may be something
that you can tweak.
So if we go back to our uh initial
question which is how do you quantify
the factuality of this text here you
would say okay the second and the third
facts are both correct. we know how
important they are. So we run this
aggregation formula and we obtain a
score of 6.
So that means that there are some errors
but we still have some things that were
still factually correct.
So this is typically how you would run
this criteria with I guess the
techniques that we have nowadays.
Okay, cool. I know I'm 2 minutes late
and with that I'm going to give it to
Shervin.
Thank you Ashin.
So before we move on to looking at
specific benchmarks, I wanted to take a
detour and look at what is happening on
the agent side of things.
So if you recall what we discussed uh
last lecture, we talked about this react
framework where you could decompose what
was going on within an within an agent
into specific steps. So it's usually
three steps can be observe, plan, act or
it can have other names. But the fact is
that you have several atomic steps that
can loop.
So if you take a look at the typical
agents inner working uh you can see a
pattern like this. Now you might wonder
how do you even evaluate such a thing.
So let's take a look at just one loop um
and then let's see together what can the
errors be in order for us to have an
idea of what would an evaluation results
mean on an agentic workflow.
So I'm going to show a slide that we had
presented
um at the previous lecture and uh we had
seen that we can decompose a tool call
into these three steps. So let's take
our favorite example um let's say you
want to find a bear near you. So you
would ask that to the model. So the
first stage is to find the right tool
call with the right argument
and then once you have found this right
tool call you need to execute it and
then based on your tool call prediction
and on the results that you obtained
from your tool you would infer the
results at the last step. So these are
three steps and you might have a series
of them in the case of an agentic
workflow where you call multiple tools
and then build up your reasoning until
reaching an answer that you then give to
the user.
Okay. So now let's look at
what can the failure modes can what can
they be at each of these steps. So first
let's take a look at possible tool
prediction errors. So the first one I
want to mention is the case where the
error is that from a user query that
obviously needs a tool that you don't
actually use the tool. So here let's
suppose that you want to find a bear.
You have the tool to find bears at hand
but you don't use it. Uh so typically if
you don't use it a possible behavior
from the model can be to uh say an
error. Um so an error by an error I mean
you know sorry I cannot do that and this
in assistant terms you can call this a
punt. So when you don't answer the
question you just fail. Uh it's called a
punt. So you might punt here. Uh you
know sorry I don't know where I can find
one. and let's see together what could
possibly cause this issue and how we
could remedy it.
So I don't know if you recall the
concept of tool router or tool selector
that we had introduced. So usually when
you are dealing with tools you don't
have just one you have multiple ones and
the number of tools that might be useful
for a large scale in the sense of number
of users LLM might be large. So you
don't want to input all the function
APIs at every call. So it might be the
case that you have this intermediary
step where you filter down the sets of
possible functions that you can put in
the preamble
and here um like these tool selectors or
tool routers
um they have the property of trying to
be recall oriented. So you want to trim
the list of functions that you want to
input in the preamble
u but you want to at least find those
that you need. So the main property here
is that you want to save on uh context
space but you still want to ensure you
know most of your use cases are still
working. So this is why here when we say
tool wer error we actually mean a recall
error. So it means it's possible that we
just didn't select the right tool among
the set of tools
and uh let's say this is the cause then
it's pretty clear we just have to adjust
the tool router in order for it to be um
like predicting the right tool. So this
can be one kind of issue. Another kind
is, hey, actually the tool was included
in this list of function APIs, but it's
just that the LLM didn't think about
using it.
So, um, so maybe this like fine teddy
bear was in there, but we just don't use
it. The LLM directly outputs a response.
So in that case um if you recall we had
mentioned techniques to teach an LLM to
use a tool. So you would need to revisit
that part and either so if if you had
trained it with SFT so you know include
this pattern maybe to train the model to
recognize it or if you had done prompt
tuning then you should revisit your
prompt in order for this call to make
sense to the model that you should use
that tool.
Okay, great. So this is one kind of uh
possible error. Another one that you
might see in the wild when you want to
debug uh agents is at the time of tool
calls. It might be the case that the
model comes up with a function name that
just simply doesn't exist.
So here I mentioned the tool
hallucination. This is what I mean by
that. So it calls a function that is
just not defined. So here our API was
called if you remember find teddy bear.
So this was the function that existed
and in this example of failure the model
tries to call the function find bear
which I haven't defined.
So uh when you see such errors you have
several potential causes. One of them
being that the model simply doesn't
ground well overall and typically it
occurs if the model is too simple.
Uh so it's an empirical observation if
it's too weak. Maybe it can make up
things that it thinks uh can be
reasonable but it doesn't actually
ground on your instructions.
And here I have no better remedy
proposal than to maybe upgrade the model
if you see that this is truly the case
and then see if this uh this is
reproducible.
Some other potential causes could be
coming from actually you. So the model
is trained on very high quality data
during its SFT stage. So it has seen
what great APIs look like. So these
tools that you define that help the user
achieve what they're looking for might
not be written in the best way. You
know, if you didn't use uh AI assistant
coding, let's say um or yeah, you don't
necessarily have to use AI assistant
coding to write this, but these are
typically a great way to check whether
your implementation makes sense from a
model standpoint. And if it doesn't then
a typical remedy is to either like
renaming the API just the function name
and the arguments
just go a long way because this is what
the model will see when it comes to your
to your tool call. It sees the API
um you know function name. It sees the
arguments and the highle descriptions.
So these are your three knobs to tune in
order to make it sound more logical and
then linked to the actual task at hand.
And then uh so you know at the very
beginning I was saying maybe the model
is too weak but actually maybe the first
thing you should check is whether the
horizontal instructions so horizontal
across tools whether these are clear
enough. Maybe [snorts]
uh the model hasn't really um understood
that it needs to use functions that are
given to it. So maybe it's just making
up function names that it believes could
have access to. So the first thing to
check would probably be to see if this
phenomenon is generalized and see if
these horizontal instructions they are
concisely saying that you should uh make
sure to use available functions
and then uh yeah on that you can iterate
on these top level instructions and uh
you know maybe iterate with uh with an
LLM itself because typically top level
instructions they're veryant important.
So you need perfect formatting and
perfect logic. So yeah, typically being
able to detail them um with with great
detail is is helpful.
Um okay, now let's see a third possible
failure cause. So let's say you have
your model and your uh user prompts, but
you just don't use the right tool. So
here if the user says find a bear near
me, one other reasonable approach would
be you know what if you just send a
message asking for a bear. You know that
would be reasonable, right? But maybe
that's not what you want to implement as
a behavior for your user. So in that
case it's not clear to the model what
approach you prefer and it is uh on your
um you know it is your responsibility to
ensure it is indeed clear. So um and
then you have to do that at two
different levels. So the first one is
you know potentially also at the tool
router level. Maybe the tool router
doesn't know that for this kind of
query, you should have the tool that you
had in mind as part of the results. So
it's possible that you have a recall
issue that you need to fix. And then the
second one is simply going back to the
APIs of both functions. Maybe they
conflict in scope. So you want to go
back to each of them and be precise into
which situations should be dealt with
with which tool. So being very um very
precise in in these APIs um just plays a
lot here.
Okay, great. So now we're going to go
through a fourth
u and last failure mode for this tool
prediction task which is what if you
have the right tool but you just don't
have the right arguments.
So you have already gone one step you
know you have found the right tool but
then this last mile of making sure that
the tool is run with what you would like
is not fulfilled. So here if I say find
a beer near me and it outputs and and it
uses the coordinates 0 0 which is u
somewhere in the southern Atlantic so
it's not likely that I'm actually there
uh you know that can reflect an issue
and
you know one possible explanation for
this is that maybe simply doesn't know
where I am because I haven't specified
in my query that I'm here at Stanford
and it just tries to make up my
coordinates. So, one uh thing that you
should uh double check is making sure
that the context uh carries the location
information. So, if I haven't provided
that as a setting on my LLM map, it's
possible it's not there. Um, and uh, and
then let's say it's not there, maybe you
would want to introduce a location
finder tool that is executed beforehand
and if it fails because I haven't given
the app the permission to see my
location, then maybe you could have a
actionable error shown to the user uh,
instead of having some dummy parameters
passed in. So this is one potential
remedy. And then the second one is uh
you know maybe it sees arguments but uh
the model just doesn't know what it
should put as input.
So that that could also be um you know
another reason and then on that you know
this is a common remedy to go back and
then retrain either the model on how it
uses these tools or rewrite the API.
So we have seen four ways to I mean four
failure modes for the tool prediction
step. Now we're going to see two more on
this tool call step.
So the first one is you know very simple
one um you know from a mindset
perspective. So know maybe your your
tool just doesn't output the right
response. So, it's a very um kind of
vague category. And as an example, maybe
uh your code logic has a bug somewhere
and it it it just returns an error. You
know, those that you see in Python,
maybe it hits some value error or like
anything else. And I just want to say um
that it might not be necessarily the
case that hitting an error is bad
because sometimes you know in the case
of finding your location
if you haven't uh provided your
permission to find the location maybe it
will hit an error and the model will
anchor on that error to convey the
status to the user. But in general, it's
not really common practice to return
errors just because the model could
interpret it as an internal tool error.
So sometimes when you you hit an error
and then you ask the model to synthetize
the tool cause it has seen. Sometimes it
just says, "Oh, sorry. I couldn't do it,
but it's my fault. It's because I
encountered an error." Doesn't really
say, you know, actionably what happened.
And instead the fix here is to uh convey
these outputs in a meaningful manner. So
uh typically you have a structured
output and you return a true output
instead of an error.
So uh yeah here um so it's a general
case just to say that just check your
tool implementation. So you have the
right arguments you you have the right
tool but you just don't have the right
value. So just a software engineering
problem, just go and fix the tool.
And the second category of issues that
we see at the backend level is when you
return no response.
And returning no response is often bad
when the tool is one that performs an
action.
So let's say last lecture we talked
about uh increasing the thermostat for
your teddy bear who was called. So if
you increase the thermostat and the tool
doesn't say anything. So the model
doesn't know if it has done the task
successfully or not. So it could well
come up with a false confirmation of hey
uh you know all is good. I have
increased the thermostat. No worries.
But it actually hasn't. So this is why a
common guidance is to always make sure
that tool calls are followed by a
meaningful output. So uh as usual you
have this like structured message and
you should take advantage of it to
convey what has happened as part of your
tool um in order to make sure that the
the model in turn knows what to convey
to the user or knows how to continue
that agent tick loop.
So yep. So always output something and
let's say you're finding you want to
find a teddy bear and you haven't found
any then here you will be surprised by
what I say but it's actually better to
output an empty JSON than just
outputting none because an empty JSON
could mean I found no bears but an
output of none doesn't say anything. So
even in that case an empty output in the
sense of you know empty JSON is
meaningful and make sure to use that
meaning in the way you encode your tool.
Okay great. So we have seen uh two more
u possible errors at the function call
level. Now let's suppose that everything
went great at the first step everything
went great at the second step. So you
have found the right tool output but now
the model has trouble to synthesize the
output into a meaningful response.
So yeah let's suppose your tool found a
bear named teddy and then the other
attributes which I haven't shown here
maybe say that they are like one mile
away from me. So yeah the teddy bear has
been found and we just have to present
it to the user. But uh if you put it to
the model, let's suppose the model says,
you know, I didn't find any bear. So
what could be the cause here? So it
could be the case that you have an
output that has information that the
model doesn't ground on. So it could be
the case that just the model lacks the
ability to refer to content that it that
was uh you know put previously. So here
I have this the same um vanilla
suggestion of um you know upgrading the
model.
So usually that doesn't happen really
anymore but it used to in early
iterations of LLMs.
There is uh you know one that is
actually one that happens fairly often.
So sometimes the tool back end returns
not only an output but a lot of output
and it's too much for the model to
properly parse what is important. So you
have maybe the information of Teddy in
there but you know it's it's it's
drowning under um an ocean of other
kinds of information that are not
useful. So the model cannot distinguish
what is helpful. And then the solution
for that is to go back to your tool
implementation and ensure that whatever
you output is meaningful to be used to
the model in the next stage.
And uh I think this goes um so this
overlaps with the third reason I put
here. So let's say your output is
trimmed already. Then another possible
explanation is maybe it's not being
presented in a meaningful way. So this
is why in Python you have these classes
where you can uh instantiate attributes
so that the output is very meaningful.
So let's say for like saying that you
have found a bear, you could return an
object called teddy bear with attributes
name, distance and so on. This is very
meaningful as opposed to maybe raw
information that it doesn't know how to
interpret.
Okay, awesome. So we have seen here
seven different failure modes over all
these categories. So these are not the
only ones you know I I have just
mentioned those that I see very often
that I thought could be helpful but you
could definitely see other failure
modes. Um does this make sense?
Do you have any questions?
Okay, great. So we can move on
um to
uh summarizing what were the common
trends in uh these failure modes. So
often times we have talked about the
modeling side where uh you know
sometimes
in improving the model's ability to
reason and ground could be the solution.
Another um you know another kind of
complaint that we have seen is uh the
relevance of what we put in the context
window. If we improve that relevance
maybe it gets better. And on the
modeling side one more um aspect is
maybe the tool wrers modeling or the
tool API modeling itself either by SFT
tuning or just prompting or even just
the API description itself. So you know
does the function make sense? Do the
arguments make sense? Does the duck
string make sense? So this is one kind.
And the other kind is the tool itself.
So maybe it just has a problem. So you
need to fix it.
Um and I just want to say that when you
deal with tools and evaluations, you
have a lot of possible errors. So one
thing that will help you to navigate
through this is to be very methodical
into categorizing kinds of errors and
then dealing with them in group. So you
see there's lots of errors and every
time that you deal with a given loss, it
may be just an adventure to solve. So
really being very organized here is
going to help you a lot.
Okay.
So with that in mind um we can delve
into the world of benchmarks. So we
talked about evaluations. Now you might
wonder how can you evaluate a large
language model uh you know let's say you
have trained everything you know how can
you compare it with respect to others.
So we're going to see together a series
of [snorts] benchmark categories that
today's benchmarks usually um you know
where where today's benchmark usually
resides. So in one of these um and we're
going to see examples for each of them.
Does that sound good?
Awesome. So we can start with a kind of
benchmark that I called a knowledge
based benchmark where we want to test if
the model is able to restitute
um given facts. So um so yeah these
facts are typically spanning uh lots of
domains. So it doesn't have to be super
precise on a given domain, but it's like
spanning like all the kind of domains
that your users may care about. And then
one prime example for this is MMLU that
we're going to see very soon. But just
before we do so, I want to say that this
knowledge benchmark
mostly but not only measures how well
pre-training was done. How well the
information in your large corpora of
data was retained by the model in order
to be helpful at inference time.
So, MMLU stands for massive multitask
language [snorts] uh language
understanding and this benchmark has um
like almost 60 different tasks that are
super diverse. So it's not just uh you
know one specific topic is just a bunch
of topics like everyday life topics or
very you know for example is there are
like law um you know medicine and
everything that you can think about and
the benchmark is redacted in a way that
can be easily
um you know measuring an LLM's
performance and weighing that
performance with respect to others. So
it's not something that is free form is
something that is um very constrained.
There is a question and then you have
four possible answers and you ask the
LLM to choose one of them. So it's a bit
like CME 295 exams. you know part of the
exam is also multiple choice questions
and you know it's a good way to
standardize the you know evaluation and
it's the same that is used here. Uh so
here um and this is also a trend that
you see across benchmarks. You don't ask
the model to just come up with some
answer and you have maybe an LLM as a
judge just giving some its opinion about
it because doing so introduces
um you know another layer of potential
errors. You know the LLM as a judge as a
mentioned isn't necessarily perfect. So
this framing enables us to to have a
hard-coded way to extract the the answer
output by the LLM. So typically you
would ask it to output the the right
letter at the end of each question which
you can then extract and then compare
with respect to the answer.
So giving some examples that what is
about what is in this benchmark. uh as I
mentioned you have all sorts of fields
uh in there and you will notice that
each problem
uh mostly requires some prior knowledge
about that topic so it's not like purely
logic that will help you solve it and I
think the last example in this slide is
a good representation of it where you
have something in the domain of medicine
and you have a bunch of numbers uh you
know patient has this and
What would you say like where would you
say is the damage? So it's typically
something that you could see in medicine
books maybe and the same goes with other
fields such as law where everything has
been codified somewhere and you need the
knowledge of that somewhere in order to
answer the question.
Okay, great. So this is the first kind.
Um and it's not the only kind of
benchmark you have. Um so it's not the
only benchmark in this category. You
have other benchmarks that are uh that
can be in this category but it's just
one of them.
A second category that you might see are
are those that are in the reasoning
space. So typically
uh these are kinds of benchmarks that
require some amount of
thoughts before outputting an answer. So
it assesses the quality of the chain of
thoughts or if you are in the reasoning
world maybe the quality of your think
tokens
but just more broadly your ability to
infer um a response based on some
reasoning and then for that I'm going to
mention two examples. So, one in the
field of math and then one other in the
field of so-called common sense
reasoning that is anchored in everyday
life. Uh, which is typically
the field that might be of interest for
your LM users and we're going to see
that very soon. So, first let's take a
look at the benchmark focus on math. So
how many of you know about AIM?
So, AIM is uh an exam that high school
students um sit for when they want to um
participates to like the Olympiads and
it's typically um it's it's a very hard
test and it's covering math topics and
um and then it's in a format that is LLM
friendly because you have uh a given
problem statement and at the end you ask
the student to write the response into a
three-digit
uh a three-digit number. So, it's very
well constrained which makes it a right
fit to benchmark LLMs
and uh you know just like the one before
it's hardcoded
and you know I give here some samples of
the AIM exam as seen this year. So as
you see, so I don't know if you can read
from afar, but it's not super simple.
You you have some, you know, one
sentence. So you think maybe it's easy,
but you actually need to write down the
reasoning before finding the answer. And
this is what we want to test the LLM
for.
And then the second kind of um reasoning
that we mentioned here was so-called
common sense reasoning. And the one that
is often used these days is um PAS. So
physical interaction question answering.
So these are tasks that are deeply
grounded into the physical real world.
So we have some samples at the next
slide that we'll show. But it is uh you
know still reasoning based questions but
that will rely on your understanding on
how things work around you not nec
necessarily math based but just you know
everyday life
and uh this time it's not multiple
choice questions over four answers like
MMLU it's over two only
and you have 20k examples And then here
a good example that I really liked from
the samples mentioned in the paper uh
was how do I find something lo I lost on
the carpet. So there is one solution
that says you know vacuum with a solid
seal and the other one is vacuum with
the hairnet
and of course when you vacuum with a
solid seal then the seal is of course
solid so no air can go through it. But
if you have a hairet, you will vacuum
the whole thing and the thing that you
lost will be caught inside of it. So
what I mentioned is common sense, but it
might not be obvious and this is what we
task the model to resolve.
Okay. So then one other major area for
benchmarks is coding where uh we want to
probe the model for solving
uh complex questions in coding and um
this has two main uses in real life. So
one is aligned with the kind of use case
that I mentioned at the end of last
lecture the one I liked regarding AI
assistant coding. So these models they
aim at being used in that setting as
well. So you should make sure that these
benchmarks
perform like these benchmarks show that
these LLMs perform well in order to be
useful to your users.
And then a second reason why uh
benchmarking on coding makes sense is
that you have all these tools that you
might want to use in an agentic setting
and then these tools are written maybe
in a Python format. So you want to
ensure that your model has uh the right
ability to read and write code so that
it can execute these tool calls and then
interpret what's coming out of them.
So these are two I would say motivations
that um that motivate us to like you
know find coding useful here you know
even to the to the folks that don't do
coding at all.
So
um yeah and then one example of such
benchmark is SWEBench.
So SWEBench is so I put a question mark
here because they didn't define exactly
you know what the acronym meant but it's
likely that it meant software
engineering benchmark. to Swiss, often
times the acronym for software
engineering.
And what they did is that they looked at
popular Python repositories,
and they filtered down those that
contained pull requests that were
solving an issue and that introduced
tests. So you have some before after
behavior that you can quantitatively
assess with the tests that are
introduced. And supposedly if you have a
pull request that introduces some test
and some fix, you can fairly assume that
these tests were not passing without the
fix and that they are passing after the
fix. So the fact that we have these
tests at hand is a good measure for us
to assess the quality of a fix.
So if you have heard of a testdriven
development, it's all about you know
having tests and ensuring they pass and
this is what it relies on.
So uh yeah and then here uh you ask
these LLMs to solve these GitHub issues
and then you assess whether they indeed
uh pass by uh by looking at the test
status before and after patching the
answer suggested by the
Okay, great. Uh so here is a very nice
um figure that the paper introducing
that benchmark gives. So you know you're
given a code base uh and then what you
ask the model for is a patch that is
just it and then uh you patch whatever
the model has provided to find the
tests. So to find the test status
and then one last area that I want to
mention in the case of uh like base
benchmarks is safety.
Uh so when you see uh fancy LLMs coming
out you usually don't see in the you
know advertisement of modeling
benchmarks
the safety part because usually safety
is
is a bit subjective with respect to the
LLM provider. So every company has its
own policy. So you cannot necessarily
compare a performance on a given
benchmark across models just because all
these providers might not claim they
want to perfectly solve that benchmark
100%.
As a result, it's not necessarily a good
measure of that field. So if you look at
model cards often times you see a safety
section being mentioned in reports to
say the work that they have done but
they don't necessarily compare models
with respect to a given benchmark.
Um and uh yeah, usually the safety
benchmarks they are fairly aligned with
what we think um you know should or
should not happen. But on top of it you
might have additional policies that
maybe uh you know just policies. So you
have some human that had to make some
decision. It might not be a universal
decision. It's just a given decision. So
the benchmark the benchmark's goal is to
be aligned with what kind of policy the
LLM provider has in mind in order to be
truly meaningful and yeah this is why
when you execute a safety benchmark
you should check the content of the
benchmark in order to put a meaning
behind it. So here let's talk about harm
bench which I am supposing it means
harmful behavior benchmark.
So this benchmark has four categories.
The so-called standard category that is
um categorizing
uh like quote unquote vanilla harmful
behavior. Then you have copyright
category that is uh assessing the
model's ability to generate copyrighted
content which we do not want. And then
the two last ones contextual and
multimodel it's like both of them are
contextual based on a given modality. So
contextual is on the the text modality
and then multimodel is with like other
model modalities than text. So we're
going to see an example at the next
slide.
And here
you don't have the same ability to
assess performance on this benchmark
based on some hard-coded match because
these harmful statements might be
open-ended.
And you cannot possibly just solve all
of these by regex matching. You know,
for example, one example in the standard
category of this benchmark
tries to uh entice
harmful behavior um into like executing
something that is harmful and um the
paper mentions like makes a distinguish
uh distinguishes something that is very
interesting. So it distinguishes
model quality with safety by saying that
if the model tries to do the harmful
behavior even if it wasn't successful
because it was not of a good quality
enough then it's enough to count the
attack as successful and then for that
they trained some classifier to
recognize these cases and yeah this is
the only benchmark
uh among those that I presented here
that is done based on a classifier that
can itself be prone to error uh compared
to others that are very grounded in uh
constraints setup values
and as promised here is like a few
examples as mentioned in the paper. So
uh here uh you know we test whether you
can unlock a door that you shouldn't
unlock and then here um the yeah the
test is on influencing someone with
respect to some election. So it's not
these are not safe behaviors and yeah
okay great so I mentioned everything uh
so far that you could solve without
tools.
Uh so of course I say you could you know
some of them you could use tools of
course to solve them but what about uh
measuring the behavior of agents.
So for here you have an interesting
benchmark called toao bench where toao
is a Greek letter that actually um you
know you can write it as tool agent
users and this is why we say toao and um
it's a benchmark that provides uh across
two different fields so the airline and
the retail field a set of tools and it
gives a set of policies is you know
things that the agent can and cannot do
and then what you do is that you have a
set of tasks. So tasks are problem
statements that you give um given user
and the goal is for the user to achieve
that task through the agent.
And the interesting thing about TaoBench
is that Towbench is language model
simulated. So the user interaction with
the agent as you can imagine cannot be
hardcoded because further turns will
depend on previous ones. So let's say
you say something as a user and your
agent decides to do something. Then you
need the context of what it has done in
order to continue the conversation. And
this is why you have the simulation
aspect that the paper introduces that is
typically done by a separate
uh big model that plays the role of the
user.
And uh yeah, here we have an example of
the task of changing a flight. So you
have a given tools, the agent tries to
help the um the user to achieve that
goal and uh at the end of it we assess
whether it's successful in doing so by
calculating a reward that's a function
of the database change. So let's say the
user has changed their tickets. So we
want to see if the database has indeed
the state that we're looking for and or
a given action. So maybe the action of
cancelling is one that is the goal of
this task. Uh so this is like part of
the reward.
And the paper that introduces this
benchmark uh talks about a concept that
is um funny word play. Um with respect
to the metric that we had that we had
talked about at the last lecture, we had
introduced pass at K. And then this
paper talks about pass hat K
which is the probability that all K
attempts succeed and then why is that uh
relevance metric here. So as you have
seen the airline and retail um domains
were ones that were chosen chosen here
and then an an agent in the loop here
could be a way to see if automating the
agent side of things could help. And in
order to truly know whether it can help
you want to have reliability and
consistency in mind. So if you execute
the the task k times, you don't want
like pass at k the probability that at
least one of them succeeds. You want the
probability that all of them succeeds
which is why this metric matters. So if
we had more time I would have derived
the formula to find
um pass hat K with respect to the um
parameters of the problem but I will
refer you to the derivation that Afin
has done last time and uh yeah I just
want you to be convinced that this is
indeed the formula. So if you're not
convinced, please feel free to do it um
at home.
And
moving on, we talked about all these
benchmarks. Now let's see how they are
grounded in reality. So by now I think
everyone of you has seen the new Gemini
launch a few days ago. So this was the
report that was sent to everyone to to
just justify that the performance here
was better. And you can see that what we
introduced here is mentioned in some
format. So the reasoning part on
aim and pa is there. And then you will
see that some of these benchmarks are
derived in a flavor that introduces um
multilinguality linguity um multi-
languages and uh so this is the case for
pika instead of p global pa and then for
coding it uses a flavor of swbench and
tool use it uses also a flavor of bench
which is towel squared bench
And
a few last words here. I just want to
say that benchmarks are here to
characterize the profile of of your LLM.
So it's not all good or all bad. Maybe
some of your LLMs will have some
strength and some weaknesses.
and your personal experience might guide
you to use one specific one with respect
to others in given situations. So if I
had to just give my personal experience,
I know that the Sony models are very
helpful for coding and whenever I want
outputs that are fast and cheap, you
know, Gemini flash is usually good. But
these are not by any means global
recommendations. you know, your own use
case and your own experience can guide
you into having a profile of models that
suits your tasks best.
And
you can interestingly plot the
performance of your models with respect
to the other dimension that you care
about which is price for example and see
for a given price what is the best model
you can use. And then the border that
you see on the best models for that
specific metric is called the parareto
frontier.
And you might have a parto frontier with
respect to several aspects. So cost,
safety, context length.
And then few words regarding data
contamination.
One thing about these benchmarks is that
they are as good as the assumption of
whether you have seen the actual
benchmark results or not. So make sure
you haven't seen them. And for that
people introduce hash values.
uh you know in the case of tool use they
introduce a block list in order to not
access websites that might contain the
responses
or uh in the case of math we have the
luxury of evaluating on new tests that
the model has for sure not seen
and a good heart's law is a very good
um adage that says a measure when a
measure becomes a target it ceases to be
a good measure
So all these benchmark results are to be
weighed against what you're truly
looking for and then these benchmark
results don't necessarily tell you
whether a model is good for you or not.
So um you know we had talked about
chatbot arena um in what one of the
previous lectures it can be one way to
balance the real life um performance of
these. But I would say ultimately you
should be the one trying out these best
models and see for yourself which one
corresponds to you best.
And with that I hope you all have a
great Thanksgiving and thank you